who I have a really interesting
description of censorship of
self-censorship also as you've been
talking about uh who's King mustache and
uh this Gap I think I hope you write
even more even more than you've written
in the book about these ideas because
it's so strong this this censorship gaps
that are created between the dormant
thought pile
and uh the kind of thing under the
speech curve yeah so first of all so I
like to think of
I think it's a useful tool as this thing
called a thought pile which is if you
have a On Any Given issue you have a
horizontal spectrum and just say I could
take your brain out of your head and I
put it on the thought pile right where
you happen to believe about that issue
now I did that for everyone in the in
the community or in a society and you're
going to end up with a big mushy pile
that I think will often should form a
bell curve if it's really politicized it
might form like a camel with two humps
because it's like concentrated here but
for a typical issue it'll just form you
know a fear of AI you're going to have a
bell curve right you know things like
this that's the thought pile now the
second thing is a line that's I call the
speech curve which is what people are
saying so the speech curve is high when
not just a lot of people are saying it
but it's being said from the biggest
platforms being said in the you know on
the you know in the New York Times and
it's being said by the president on you
know in the State of the Union those
things are the top of the speech curve
now and and then as you know and then
when the speech occurs lower it means
it's being said either whispered in
small groups or it's just not very many
people are talking about it now a
healthy when a when a free speech
democracy is healthy on a certain topic
you've got the speech curve sitting
right on top of the thought pile they
they mirror each other which is
naturally what would happen more people
think something is going to be said more
often and from higher platforms
what censorship does and that censorship
can be from the government I so I use
the tale of King mustache and King
mustache she's a little tiny Tyrant and
he's very sensitive and people are
making fun of his mustache and they're
saying he's not a good King and he does
not like that so what does he do he
enacts a policy and he says anyone who
has heard criticize anyone who's heard
criticizing me or my mustache or my rule
will be put to death
and immediately at the town because his
father was very liberal it was always
free speech in in his kingdom but now
King mustache has taken over and he's
saying this is a new new rules now and
so a few people yell out and they say
that's not how we do things here
and that moment is what I call a moment
of truth
did the king's guards stand with the
principles of the kingdom and say yeah
King mustache that's not what we do in
which case he would kind of have to he's
nothing he can do
or are they going to execute so in this
case it's as if he laid down an electric
fence over a part of this thought pile
and said no one's allowed to speak over
here the speech curve maybe people will
think these things but the speech curve
cannot go over here
but the electric fence wasn't actually
electrified until the king's guards in a
moment of truth get scared and say okay
and they hang the five people who spoke
out so in that moment that fence just
became electric and now no one
criticizes King mustache anymore so I
use this as an allegory now of course he
has a hard cudgel because he can execute
people but now when we look at the U.S
what you're seeing right now is a lot of
pressure
which is very similar in electric fence
is being laid down saying no one can
criticize these ideas
and if you do you won't be executed
you'll be canceled you'll be you'll be
you'll be fired now what is that fence
electrified from there no they don't
they can't actually they're not working
the company they can't fire you but they
can start a Twitter mob when someone
violates that speech curve when someone
violates that speech rule and then the
leadership at the company has the moment
of truth
and what the leaders should do is stand
up for their company's values which is
almost always in favor of the employee
and say look you know even if they made
a mistake they make people make mistakes
we're not going to fire them or maybe
that person actually said something
that's reasonable we should discuss it
but either way we're not going to fire
them and if they said no what happens is
the Twitter mom actually doesn't have
they can't execute you they they go away
and the fence is proven to have no
electricity what's been the problem with
the past few years is what's happened
again and again is the leader gets
scared and they don't they get scared of
the tournament when they fire them boom
that fence has electricity and now
actually if you cross that
it's not just you know a threat like you
will have you'll be out of a job like
it's really bad like you'll have a huge
penalty you might not be able to feed
your kids
so that's an electric fence that goes up
now what happens when an electric fence
goes up and it's proven to actually be
electrified the speech curve morphs into
a totally different position and now
these new people say instead of having
the kind of marketplace of ideas you
know turns into a kind of a natural bell
curve they say no no these ideas are
okay to say not just okay you'll be
socially rewarded and these ones don't
that's the rules of their own Echo
chamber that they're now applying to
everyone and it's working and so the
speech curve distorts and so you end up
with now instead of one region which is
a region of kind of active communal
thinking what people are thinking and
saying you now have three regions
you have a little active communal
thinking but mostly you now have this
dormant thought pile which is all these
these opinions that suddenly everyone's
scared to say out loud everyone's
thinking but they're scared to say
everyone's thinking but no one's saying
and then you have this other region
which is this the the approved ideas of
this now cultural kind of dictator
and those are being spoken from the
largest platforms and they're being
repeated by the president and they're
being repeated all over the place you
know even though people don't believe it
and that's this Distortion and what
happens is the the society becomes
really stupid because active communal
thinking is the region where we can
actually think together and now no one
can think together and it gets it gets
siled into small private conversations
it's really powerful what you said about
institutions and so on it's not trivial
to from a leadership position to be like
no we we defend the employee or defend
the
um yeah the employee the person with us
on our like because we don't there's
because there's no actual
uh ground to the any kind of violation
we're hearing about so the mob they
resist the mob it's ultimately to the
leader I guess of a particular
institution of a particular company and
it's difficult oh yeah no no it's not I
don't if it were easy it wouldn't it it
there wouldn't be all of these failings
and by the way this is that's the immune
system failing that's the liberal immune
system of that company failing but also
then it's an example which means a lot
of other you know it's failing to kind
of to the country it's not easy of
course it's not because what because we
have primitive Minds that are wired to
care so much about what people think of
us and even if we're not gonna you know
maybe first of all we're scared that
it's going to start a because they're
you know what you know what what do mobs
do
they don't just say I'm going to
criticize you I'm going to criticize
anyone who still buys your product I'm
going to criticize anyone who goes on
your podcast so it's not just you it's
now suddenly if if if if Lex becomes
tarnished enough now I go on the podcast
and people are saying oh I'm not buying
his book he went on Lex Friedman no no
thanks right and now I get by there it's
a call I call it a smear web like you've
been smeared and it's so we're in such a
you know bad time that it smeared
travels to me and now memo someone who
buys my book and tries to share it
someone said you're buying that guy's
book you know he goes on Lex Freeman you
see how this happens right so that
hasn't happened in this case but that so
we are so wired hey that is kind of bad
right like that is actually like bad for
you but but we're wired to care about it
so much because it meant life or death
back in the day yeah yeah
and luckily in this case we're both uh
you probably can smear each other in
this conference this is wonderful I I
smear you all given given the nature of
your book
um
what what do you think about freedom of
speech as a term and as an idea as a way
to resist the mechanism this mechanism
of uh dormant thought pile and
artificially generated speech
this ideal of the freedom of speech and
protecting speech and celebrating speech
well so this is this is kind of
the point I was talking about earlier
about
King mustache
made a rule against for he's created
official because I just I just love the
the one of the amazing things about your
book as you get later and later in the
book you cover more and more difficult
issues as a way to illustrate the
importance of the vertical perspective
but there's something about using
hilarious drawings throughout that make
it much more fun and it like it takes
you away from the personal somehow and
you start thinking in the space of ideas
versus like outside of the tribal type
of thinking so it's a really brilliant I
mean I would advise for anybody to do
con when they write controversial books
to have hilarious drawings it's true
like put a silly stick figure in your
thing and it lightens it does it
lightens the mood it gets people's guard
down a little bit you know and it works
it it reminds people that like we're all
friends here right like we're you know
that's like you know laugh at ourselves
laugh at the laugh at the fact that
we're like in a culture War a little bit
and now we can talk about it right as
opposed to like getting like religious
about it but but basically like king
must have had no First Amendment he said
we the government is censoring right
which is very common around the world
right Government Center all them the U.S
you know again there's some you can
argue there's some controversial things
recently but basically the U.S the First
Amendment isn't the problem
right no one is being arrested for
saying the wrong thing but this graph is
still happening and so so freedom of
speech when people if what people like
to say is if someone's can't complaining
about like cancel culture and saying you
know this is this is you know an
anti-free speech
people like to point out no it's not the
government's not arresting you for
anything this is called like you know
the free market buddy like this is
called
you know you're putting your ideas out
and you're getting criticized and your
precious Marketplace of ideas there it
is right and I've gotten this a lot
and this is not making a critical
distinction between cancel culture and
criticism culture
um
criticism culture is a little bit of
this kind of high wrong idea lab stuff
we talked about criticism culture
attacks the idea and and and and and and
and
encourages further
discussion right it enlivens discussion
it makes everyone smarter
cancel culture attacks the person very
different can criticism culture says
here's why this idea is so bad let me
tell you cancer culture says here's why
this person is bad and no one should
talk to them and they should be fired
and what does that do it doesn't live in
the discussion it makes everyone scared
to talk and it's the opposite it shuts
down discussion so you still have your
first amendment but first amendment plus
cancel culture equals you might as well
be in king must you might as well have
government censorship right
First Amendment plus criticism culture
great now you have this vibrant
Marketplace of ideas so
there's a very clear difference
um and so when when people criticize the
cancel culture and then someone says oh
see you're so sensitive now you look
you're doing the cancel culture yourself
you're trying to punish this person for
critics like no no no
we every good liberal and nice and I
mean that in the lower case which is
that anyone who believes in Liberal
democracies regardless of what they
believe should stand up and say no to
cancel culture and say this is not okay
regardless of what the actual topic is
and that makes them a good liberal
versus if they're trying to cancel
someone who's just criticizing they're
doing the opposite now they're shutting
so it's the opposite things but it's
very easy to get confused you can see
people take advantage of the and
sometimes they just don't know it
themselves the the lines here can be
very confusing the wording can be very
confusing and be without that wording
suddenly it looks like someone who's
criticizing cancel culture is
canceling but they're not